I spent so much of my life terrified of
what I was going to become and whether I
was going to be right here right now God
how much time did I waste afraid I
wasn't going to be right here right now
if I could change the only thing I'd
change about my whole life would be
fearing less that I wouldn't get right
here the place I was going anyway
probably my favorite ever video from or
Marcus imagine that where you're going
to end up the achievement of your goals
the attainment of your Pursuits are
predestined you're going there no matter
how much you fear or worry now you still
need to do the work you still need to do
the things but you don't need to fear
about completing the work or worry about
whether you'll do the things how
differently would you experience life
you'd be able to just be in the world
but not of the world doing the things
but not afraid of the things it's good
to be reminded of when we find ourselves
gripping too hard to fears or
expectations because why fear about
whether you're going to go to the place
that you were going all along